[Music]
[Applause]
you
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
good evening everybody at
the table and welcome we're so glad to
have you with us tonight
um as we continue how many months
is this now of socially distanced
church this is such a different um
i don't know it's a different time in in
the world i guess
and um i hope that your
month of december is off to a good start
as we enter into the holiday season this
is definitely
um just such a different time and
experience for all of us and we
want to be here with you as you walk
through it
and we want to continue to support you
and
um we hope you know that you're not
alone during this time
um there's enough going on in our
country as it is
and to add all the emotions and the
busyness and
everything that comes with the holiday
season can be
overwhelming um so we're here
and we're glad to be with you in this
time
um speaking of the holidays
um as we approach christmas and
christmas
eve at the table our hope is
to be able to offer an in-person
outdoor socially distanced um
and you know as safe as possible service
um on december the 24th on christmas eve
at 3 30 p.m we would be having that it's
an outdoor service at pleasant valley
united methodist church
in saxi um which is our typical
location when we meet in person and
obviously that is going to be contingent
upon
how numbers are looking in our
area locally over the next two weeks so
we will keep you
updated as much as we can but
thank you for you know kind of being
willing to
play this by ear along with us because
honestly we want to do what is best for
our entire community
and and we won't know for sure until the
time
draws a little bit nearer so if you want
to just tentatively mark that in your
calendars
december 24th christmas eve at 3 30 p.m
we would be gathering outside for that
um so um we'll keep you up to date on
all the details
in regards to that and then in the
meantime
we're gonna continue forward with um the
series that we started a couple of weeks
ago
called stretch then what to do when life
pushes you to the limits
and it feels very applicable to our life
right now
i felt um i was laughing earlier as i
was like
thinking like i look this is my i'm very
in theme right now with our
with our series um a couple weeks ago
brett talked about just being present
and you know um not taking on
what has happened in the past or getting
overwhelmed with what may be coming in
the future
but that we have what we need for this
current moment one of my
favorite bible verses is in first peter
where it says
you have everything you need for life
and godliness through the power of
christ and
i tell myself that all the time but it
really truly is a
practice in being present to the current
moment and realizing
what i need for this moment has been
given to me
and i feel like this entire series is
kind of our way of leaning into how to
do that better
and i had a quote i wanted to share on
that
topic um by wood uh sorry wayne w
oyer i have my journal here um where i
wrote it down and it says
peace is the result of retraining your
mind
to process life as it currently is
rather than as you think it should be
and i thought that was just a good
um way to frame our time as we move into
worship mindy's going to be leading us
tonight
and um i thought we could just as a
community right now
open up our hearts and minds and pray
together
to just truly be present to this
current moment that we're in together
right now and
to pray that god would be i really have
full permission to speak to us
and move in our hearts and that we would
have the courage to accept
all that's going on in and around us to
face it
and to let god lead us into that
territory so
um if you guys would pray with me we're
about to get started
god i just thank you for each person who
calls the table home
i thank you for those who may not call
it home and are
looking for a home right now um
and for those who may just be visiting
or dropping in tonight god
i um just want to acknowledge that this
is your table
and you have prepared it for each person
for each one of us so
may we come ready and hungry and
um open to whatever you have for us in
this time
god wait uh may we
allow ourselves to truly be present
to the work that you're doing in and
through and around us
right now so we come
accepting all the circumstances
that are out of our control
and we come surrendering all the
emotions
and the fears
that might be attached to each one of
those things
god we remind ourselves that you are
aware of
all of that and you are beside us in it
so would you lead us into this time
as you always do so faithfully
and continue to walk through a walk
beside us in this
we give it over to you in jesus name
amen mindy you can go ahead and
kick us off
[Music]
hey guys
you unravel me
with the melody
you surround me with
a song of deliverance from my
enemies till all my fears
are gone
and i'm no longer a slave to fear
i am a child
of god i'm no longer a slave to fear
no i am a child
of god
[Music]
from my mother's womb
you have chosen me
and love has called my name
i've been born again into your family
your blood flows
through my veins
and i'm no longer a slave to fear
no i am a child of god
i'm no longer a slave to fear
no i am a child
of god i'm no longer a slave to fear
i am a child of god
i'm no longer a slave to fear
no i am a child
of god
oh
[Music]
you split the sea so i could walk
right through it my fears are drowned in
perfect
love
you rescued me so i could stand
and sing i am a child
of god you split
you split the sea so i could walk
right through it my fears
so i could stand and sing
i am a child
of god i
am a child of god
[Music]
and i'm no longer slave to fear
i am a child of god
and i'm no longer a slave to fear
no i am a child
of god
your promise still stands
great is your faithfulness
your faithfulness
i'm still in your hands
this is my confidence
you've never failed me
yet
walking around these walls
i thought by now they'd fall
[Music]
but you have never failed me
waiting for change to come
knowing the battles won
[Music]
for you have never failed me
yet
your promise still stands
great is your faithfulness
your faithfulness
i'm still in your hands
this is my confidence
you never failed me
yet
[Music]
and i know the night won't last
your word will come to pass
my heart will sing your
again
jesus you're still enough
keep me within your love
my heart will sing your praise again
your promise still stands
great is your faithfulness
your faithfulness
i'm still in your hands
this is my confidence
you never failed
your promise still stands
great is your faithfulness
your faithfulness
i'm still in your hands
this is my confidence
you never failed me
[Music]
yet
i've seen you move you
move the mountains and i believe
i see you do it again
[Music]
where there was no way and i believe
i'll see you do it again
see you do it again
do it again
your promise still stands
great is your faithfulness
your faithfulness
i'm still in your hands
this is my confidence
you've never failed me
yet
you never fail us
you stay right with us
we worship you now
no matter what comes
[Music]
you are here god you
are here
[Music]
over the hills and every
go tell it on the mountain
that jesus christ
is born
[Music]
watch
by night
behold throughout the
heavens they're
shown a holy
light go
tell it on the mountains
over the hills and
everywhere go
tell it on the mountains
that jesus christ is born
down in a lonely
manger the humble
christ was born
and god's intersalvation
thy blessed christmas
[Music]
over the years and everywhere
go tell it on the mountains
that jesus christ
is born
as i was um getting ready for worship
this week
i was looking up christmas carols and
strangely ended up on wikipedia and
reading the definition or i guess kind
of the context of
different carols and why they were
written
and it was quite interesting and
educational and
this one stood out to me because um
it was an old negro spiritual
and it was written in the 1800s and um
i was just thinking about some of the
other songs that i had been playing
through for this set
and just kind of adopting that posture
of
you know sometimes even when we don't
know the end of the story and we might
be in
a difficult part of the story
we're still choosing to believe that we
are in the hands of god
and that he's holding us there that his
promise is still good
enough that he's still working
something in the midst of our story and
that we don't know what the end is yet
[Music]
and i was thinking about the people that
might have been writing
go tell it on the mountain in a day that
was
much less freer
than the one we're living in right now
and we all know it's not a cakewalk
these days um either but
you know the price was perhaps higher
for
a larger amount of people back then and
i was just thinking about
someone writing this down song and
singing it as
kind of this promise this hope
that they're standing on even in the
midst of
a world that was very cruel and unkind
and just claiming that that hope that
things aren't perfect things aren't
where we want them to be
but i'm standing on a mountain
and i'm saying to the world that there
is a hope that is coming
there is someone greater that has come
to rescue us that has come to redeem us
that has come to meet us
in our pain and it just took on a
completely different meaning to me than
this kind of
i don't know try quaint christmas carol
that i've always
thought was a little bit bizarre
but i was thinking of shepherds
in a position that probably wasn't very
esteemed
meeting angels and
and thinking the world isn't perfect
it's not where we want it to be
but hope is coming and then fast forward
to the 1800s
and communities gathering together to
sing this song saying the world isn't
perfect it's not where we want it to be
but hope is coming and that same promise
is something that we can claim today
so i just want us to sing that chorus
one more time
not just as a proclamation for right now
but even for the future
as we look forward to more hope to come
more light in our world
[Music]
go tell it on the mountain
over the hills and
every
go tell it on the mountain
that jesus christ
is born
go tell it on the mountain
over the hills and
everywhere
go tell it on the mountain
that jesus christ
is born that jesus
christ is born
[Music]
thanks guys thank you mindy good evening
everyone
uh grace and peace welcome to the table
and um also thank you maggie
for doing our welcome and um and then
scott is doing tech
and sarah's kind of doing hospitality
behind the scenes
for us tonight and so thank y'all
for making making this possible and of
course welcome to all of you
thank you for being here uh with us
and you know when i think of like the
table and and kind of who we
are so basically we're we're a com
community um
with certain values and we we feel
really called
uh to be thoughtful uh in how we
do life and faith in church to be
inclusive
uh eclectic we want to draw from
different
perspectives and not just be kind of
very you know narrow
um we want to be communal you know we
want to be in each other's lives and
finally want to be vulnerable
like really um real because that's where
transformation happens
uh and so so that's that's who we are
and and so everything we do
um you know from the songs we sing the
prayers we pray
to to every word of my talk tonight
we're really seeking to align
with those values um because that's who
god's
you know called us to be so um i think
you know for many of you you know those
values but i want to keep them in front
of us
and for those who may be um new that's a
little bit of
insight just into um you know who we are
and so i'm very excited to uh kind of
jump in
to tonight so we're in part three as
maggie
discussed part three in our series
titled stretch
then what to do when life pushes you to
the limit
and uh you know i've been kind of
pondering
how 2020 is a bit like a stretch
uh but a stretch you've ever done a
stretch that goes too
deep that's kind of 2020. i remember one
day
uh i was stretching out on my floor uh
because i'm in my mid-30s
and um i have to stretch
like or else i can't run so i was
stretching out after a run
and uh it was you know it was one of
those very like
you know not all stretches are the same
some are more vulnerable than others
so i was in this this like pose where
um i was based on all fours and i had
like my knees kind of flared out on the
carpet
and i was you know i was supposed to see
stretching those tendons that run right
up the inside of your legs
this is vulnerable and so there i am in
this stretch and
and uh and i'm not what you call a
flexible person
and then all of a sudden my son oak uh
he barges into the room
and he of course sees dad in the perfect
wrestling position
and i literally it's almost like it
happened in slo-mo where i'm like
[Music]
when he's like and he just comes and
like
jumps on my back and i'm like no no and
i mean
y'all the tension like i was like oh my
gosh it's
my tendons are about to pop like it was
it was scary
and so you know if normal life is a
you know kind of a standard
uncomfortable stretch
then uh my son oak is 2020.
just piling it on like you think you can
handle this try
try this one like oh my gosh that's um
that's the year
right and i mean we laugh um but
honestly we left so we don't cry
i mean goodness this year there's just
been a lot of there's been heartache
um disruption fear
uh of course you know sickness and um
for some of you you know death i mean
it's it's been
what a what a year uh and so what you
know what we're doing in this series
is is just kind of re-centering you know
looking again to the scriptures
i'm looking again to the god we've come
to know in jesus
uh for some some resources some wisdom
some insight to help us um just be able
to
at the very least survive at best
hopefully thrive
um in this season so a quick side note
before i jump in
uh you know i linked to this uh to an
article or a video a talk in my e-letter
this um this past week
and i uh about depression and i want to
just name
um you know when we're in a series like
this that's kind of touching on things
of like mental health and
um this theory this message tonight will
be about our words we speak
um i i wouldn't just kind of name
that there's a difference you know
between being stretched thin
as the series talks about uh kind of
normal human
overwhelm experiencing unpleasant
emotions
um there's a difference between that and
being in the midst
of like clinical major depression
uh where you're in a you know not just
like a rough few days
or even a week but like where weeks and
months on end
um you you are unable to experience
any sort of happiness or peace or or joy
at all
from weeks maybe in months at a time uh
you know if that's you well i think this
series
you know it can't hurt um i don't want
you to think it shouldn't like it should
just replace
you you know seeing um a doctor you know
or a therapist or a health professional
in some way
um and i know there's kind of a bit of a
stigma sometimes in spiritual circles in
in religion and church around like well
don't you have the faith
but in the same way you know i wouldn't
tell someone with diabetes like hey
um just have faith you know
i'd be like well you know you know
pray and all the things but also take
your medicine
it's kind of similar here so um get the
help you know that you need
and if you need resources references
feel free to to reach out to myself on
that
um all right so i want to name that kind
of upfront
uh but with that in mind let's go ahead
and jump in the message tonight it's
titled
raise your words and i came across this
quote
a few weeks ago that i just love
i've become slightly obsessed with it uh
it's from the persian
poet and mystic rumi that's a very
shortened version of his name
but i cannot pronounce his full name so
we'll go with roomie
and uh he said this raise your words
not your voice it is rain
that grows flowers not thunder
isn't that lovely raise your words
not your voice it is rain that grows
flowers
not thunder raise your words
raise your words that's god's word to us
tonight
and i i love the whole like the kind of
the bigger point that rumi is making
here about how
often you know the louder our voices get
um not always but often the stupider we
are
becoming um the more unlife-giving
and true whatever we are saying probably
is
um again not always but you know
but the part i've really been obsessed
with uh
is really that opening line those first
three words
raise your words that's been god's
prophetic word to me by prophetic i just
mean you know
spirit inspired uh a a timely
word i just kind of send some saying
like brett
raise your words and um just to be clear
here's what i mean by this
by this idea raise your words perhaps
it's it's um
what room it might be a little bit
different but this is kind of my
interpretation this is how i'm running
with it tonight
um by raise your words i i mean um to
intentionally orient my speech
towards the good and the beautiful
and the true raise your words that's to
intentionally orient my speech
towards the good the beautiful and the
true you see when we
when we raise our words when we orient
them towards the good the beautiful and
the true we are
actually bringing our speech
into a into alignment with reality
itself
by by reality i mean god right
god who is god what is god god is good
god is beauty god is truth
and so the deep structure of reality
is what goodness beauty truth
so when we speak right we're bringing
our words into alignment with who
god is now uh
you i can imagine some people saying
like well
my life in the world don't look so good
and beautiful
right now fair enough i get it
uh and it's true that on you know on the
surface
of the world everything can be crazy i
mean the bible names that
you know creation through sin it has
become something other than god
intended um but but
although the world is whatever you want
to call it you know fallen
broken fractured imperfect although
pandemics uh can rage
uh still god is god
and so the chaos of your life and my
life
is not the truest thing pandemics are
not the truest
thing god is the truest thing
i feel like basically in different ways
that's my message like every week
god is the truest thing which means
you know reality at its deepest level
is still good and beautiful and
true and thus as followers of christ as
people
um learning to love we want our speech
to be oriented towards what towards the
good the beautiful and the true
so with that kind of definition of raise
your words in mind um here's here's kind
of my big idea
raise your words change your life or
sorry change your story
change your story transform your life
raise your words change your story
change your story
transform your life and i don't know
about you
but i feel that lately i have been
much more tempted than usual to uh
well to you know to lower my words
isn't this what we do we we lower our
words
to the level of whatever we perceive our
life
to be uh and so i've been reflecting
like why
why do i so often lower my words let me
give you a few reasons a
i lower my words honestly because i'm
afraid of looking naive
i i want everyone you know around me to
think i'm a realistic
person i'm mature i i see the problems
i'm not pollyanna
right so i don't want to be overly sunny
or um you know looking on the bright
side
too much because honestly that seems
kind of juvenile
and i don't you know i don't want to be
that so so instead
i sort of lower my words to look and
sound realistic
but the truth is i'm not necessarily
being more realistic
because frankly i'm always interpreting
my life
and the world around me i'm always
telling a story
and make no mistake about it it's a it's
an interpretation it's a story
i'm making up um we'll touch on that a
little bit later
so that's um that's one reason you know
i'm just kind of afraid of looking naive
um also i i'm kind of just afraid of
standing out
this is sort of similar to my previous
point but it's this one's kind of a
little more
emphasizing the social element you know
what everyone else is doing
everyone else is lowering their words
every
everyone else is negative and i'm a
social creature i don't want to be part
of the gang
i want to be one of the guys or you want
to be one of the gals or whatever so
we're
you know we're tempted to drop our words
to the level of everyone else because we
don't want to stand
out why do i so often lower my words
well another reason i lower my words
because my brain is biased towards the
negative
this was the topic of the sermon two
weeks ago
so i won't you know dwell on it too long
but in short our brains
are are constantly wired to do what to
scan the environment for threats
and bad news that's what our brains are
wired
to do they're not wired to scan the
environment for the good the beautiful
and the true
no it's it's the it's the negative it's
the sad that's like the default mode
this is
why um the neurologist dr rick hansen he
kind of summed it up by saying
that our brains are velcro
for negative experiences right very
sticky
and teflon just slick for positive ones
velcro for negative experiences teflon
for positive ones
and and this is why you know goodness
and beauty
just kind of slot they just glide right
through us as though they didn't even
happen
uh and and this becomes a real problem
um so i think there's kind of a
biological component to
to why i lower my words uh the last
reason i lower my words just frankly
because it's easier
you know it feels natural to lower my
words it's like
it's like breathing it's like uh it's
like a
breathing exercise by some twisted yoga
instructor
breathing in
i know my life is crappy
breathing out i am discouraged
depressed and distraught see
it's so easy it's it's so isn't it so
easy it's just so
easy to complain so easy to be bitter
so easy to say nothing in my life
ever works out it's it's just flat out
easier so
so in short it's you know it's socially
acceptable it's biologically ingrained
uh and it's just flat out easier to just
go with the social and the psychological
flow and and lower my words
and just to be clear if
if you want your life to go exactly how
it has been going
uh then by all means you know carry on
if you're content with your
your mental emotional spiritual health
then
two thumbs up for you uh but if you're
like me and you feel you have some
growing
to do if you want to write a new
chapter if you want to bring your story
into
deeper alignment with the story
that god is trying to write for you
and with you then uh brothers and
sisters
you must raise your words
raise your words raise your words
church raise your words if we were in
person i would say can i get an amen
like come on people when when everything
around you
is falling apart raise your
words when everyone around you
is falling apart raise your words raise
your words when the job
falls through raise your words when
sickness up ends your life raise your
words
when school or work it is is
crushing when the doctor says
you have a lump when your spouse walks
out the door
when your child is on drugs when you're
not sure if the money is there for
christmas
elevate your speech raise
your words in other words it's precisely
when we are most tempted to
lower our words that we must raise them
like that's the moment
right when we're most tempted to lower
them that's when we have to raise them
uh proverbs chapter 18 verse 21 says
this
life and death are in what
in perfect church attendance in knowing
all of the right bible verses
no life and death are in the power
of the tongue that is to say
in your speech in your
words i've seen
marriages uh completely
ruined wrecked merely
by the words people spoke to one another
and i've seen marriages brought back
from the dead
because of words like these i'm
sorry that's like
the simplest words and sometimes the
most
difficult i'm sorry or how can i be
there
for you how was your day
what i'm feeling right now is
or thank you thank you so much
for not only what you do but for who you
are
words like you are a gift
to me or
i don't say it enough but i am so
grateful for you
what's going on there that's called
raising your words it's elevating
your speech as i was i'm writing this
message i realized
i just flat out don't do this enough
with my kids
i mean kind of with everyone but
especially my kids like i just
lack the intentionality to clearly
name how much i value them in really
specific ways
so i've just kind of felt prompted i
literally i'm like writing and i stop
because you know i'm working from home
right now and um
and they were there i guess this must
have been thanksgiving break or
something so the kids were there
and so i took a few minutes and i
literally like one by one i call them
each of them into the room and i sit
them down honestly they probably thought
they were getting in trouble
like i'm like hey come in here sit down
in bed um i mean i wasn't mean about it
but uh so and then i i just kind of got
in bed with him and i held their hands
and i looked each one of them in the eye
and i just
took just like a minute just to name the
ways i could see them growing up
and maturing um you know the beautiful
character traits
kind of blossoming in them just just
kind of name me how much i value
and love them and i mean you can imagine
their reaction like all of them
immediately they just got these huge
embarrassed kind of smiles on their
faces
and then each one of them at the very
end when i finished
like all three kind of spontaneously
threw their arms
around my neck and it just kind of
washed over me like oh my gosh
brett you've got to raise your words
with your kids more often um
you know some of you may have seen uh
this video kind of made the rounds a few
years ago
but it's just so powerful it's the it's
a special education teacher
um who takes 10 minutes at the beginning
of every
um kind of day every class to name
what to name the good the beautiful the
true uh in each of his
um students and i just i think it's just
a perfect example of what we're
talking about so um scott's gonna go
ahead and
roll this clip for us
[Music]
you sir are an amazing student you're
very funny
you're very smart you do a great job
every day
and you make everyone laugh because
you're so silly special education
teacher chris ulmer starts
each morning a little different than
most educators
he takes the time to compliment each and
every one of his students at main spring
academy in jacksonville florida i think
you are a brilliant student
i love having you in my class awesome
you're great you're funny
you're silly you're fast you're strong
you're athletic
you're a great soccer player you're very
smart
yes you've been doing a great job in
just a few days the video has been
shared over 20
000 times and has been viewed by over a
million people
chris creates videos to help spread
acceptance for his students and shows
the unique ways he teaches
do you want to be friends with everyone
yeah
doesn't matter what color they are he's
had the same group of kids for the last
three years and he has seen changes in
the students behavior and progress
if you want your favorite book if you
don't know where to look just ask for a
little help
if it's dark it's scary
and asks for a little help be sure to
watch inside edition
so good i love the uh the part where
he's like going through this list
uh he's like you're great you're good at
soccer and the kid goes
i know it's what's he doing
that that teacher is raising his
words uh a number of you also you might
have heard the story
of the uh the two salesmen who went down
to africa in the early 1900s
and they were sent down to just to see
if there was any opportunity for selling
shoes
and they wrote telegrams back to england
one of them wrote situation hopeless
stop they don't wear shoes
the other one wrote glorious opportunity
they don't have any shoes yet you see we
are
this comes back to my earlier point we
are storytelling creatures
we are always already having experiences
then making sense of those experiences
interpreting them uh and kind of
integrating them into ourselves by doing
what the words we speak
telling stories i mean you come home at
the end of the day
how was your day what do you do you tell
a story i mean this is
this is who we are um but remember
because of our biology
um because of social pressure because of
even just socialization how we've all
kind of been raised because of our
lack and my lack of spiritual depth and
100 other things
what happens we lower our words
we lower our words
we tell bad stories you know which is
why
um i i said like raise your words
change your story right when you raise
your words you change your story
and when you change your story you
transform
your life and you know with all of our
talk tonight
about speech and stories and words
it seems uh not insignificant
that jesus is called in the gospel of
john specifically the what
the word of god you ever thought about
that
the word of god the the life the person
of jesus
is exactly what god wanted to say to us
and god in christ has told a beautiful
a fantastic a dramatic story a story
about a people
us humanity who has wandered far from
home but who through the love of god
in jesus who through cross and
resurrection
and now the presence of the holy spirit
we are being invited
into god's story and it's a it's a new
story
it's a story of freedom of hope
of healing of restored relationship and
reconciliation it's a
it's a story where god has raised his
words and he has spoken over us
words of acceptance words of forgiveness
words of love which is why when god
then says to us go ahead
raise your words it's it's not an
angry command it's not
raise your words or else it's come
alongside me
and learn learn
how we speak in this family god's
family and so tonight that's the
invitation
raise your words and here's how i'd like
to
to close out uh if you um are
somewhere where you have either your
phone close by
let's get real you're americans of
course your phone is close by
but on the off chance it's not if not
you can grab like you know a journal or
your piece of a piece of paper and a
pencil just anything to
write and here's what i want you to do i
want you to write down
um the word or the phrase
uh that you will no longer be
saying that it's a word or phrase where
you've been lowering your words
so maybe it's a phrase like um i i'm
i'm all alone or
no one loves me or my parents screwed my
life up or
my boss is the worst you know what
whatever
that that that language is that you've
been lowering your words
um and then what i want you to do is is
name
um or basically jot down
the new phrase that you're going to say
instead
so you know for example instead of i'm
so lonely maybe it's
um you know i'm ready to make friends
instead of
no one loves me it's i'm valuable and
i'm worthy
of love and so on so name the low
word or phrase you're letting go of and
then name the new
word or phrase uh the raised word or
phrase that you're
embracing and so as you do that uh
mindy's going to go ahead and play some
music
give you a little time to write and
reflect and then we'll go ahead and
close out so
god bless you all grace and peace
[Music]
i'm no longer a slave
to fear
i am a child
of god
[Music]
i'm no longer
safe to fear
no i am a child of god
i'm no longer a slave to fear
i am a child
of god
you split the sea so i could
walk right through it
my fears are drowned in perfect
love
you rescued me so i could stand
and sing i am
a child of god
you split the sea so i could walk
right through it
my fears are drowned in perfect
love oh
you rescued me so i could stand
and sing i am
a child of god
i am a child of god
and now you can go to maggie
[Laughter]
uh my heart is so full just
honestly i mindy thank you for that time
and um goodness
brett what you shared tonight i just
was imagining as mindy was playing just
how what would it be like for an entire
community of
people to change their stories
and to live according to a different
storyline
um oh my goodness i just
i just think that's so beautiful it's so
beautiful and hopeful for me
and um something i pray that we can all
live into
um i loved i loved what brett had to say
about
aligning our words with what is true and
beautiful
and good um so good
so good um so
i'm praying for all of us to have grace
and uh fortitude
and persistence as we pursue that this
week
and um for all of you
who joined us tonight if you are needing
a way
to learn more about who we are as a
community or if you're
new um around here and just want to know
more of our story
if you've been around for a while but
you're looking on how to move forward
what are next steps or
how do i get connect with with some of
the people here or meet some of the
community
even during this time of covid we still
have groups that meet throughout the
week some online
um some are trying to practice you know
safe ways of meeting in person
um you can go to our website at
thetabletx.org
and get all the information on our
meetups and more
and you can contact us through that or
our facebook page
send us a message if you're needing help
right now during this season
if you're going through something hard
and you need specific support
we want to be there for you and with you
so please reach out don't hesitate to
send us
shoot us an email and get on the website
and contact us or go to our facebook and
message us there
we would love to hear from you and if
the table is um resonating with you
with our vision and our values is that
something you really connect with and
feel is important
and want to help support the ongoing
work that we're doing here
um we invite you to also give there
on our website thetabletx.org so you can
find all the links
and that you need there and for this
week i just want to send you out with
a very known benediction from the book
of numbers
um it is numbers chapter 6
verse 24 through 26 and it says
the lord bless you and keep you
the lord make his face shine upon you
and be gracious to you the lord
turn his face towards you and give you
peace
we wish you well god bless you have a
great week
you